uh
it looks like it looks like nine no
hey put this one here
okay german script as a chair of the
house state federal agent the veteran
affairs committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency delivered by the governor as a
result of the covers 19th pandemic
and in accordance with house 167 and the
governor's emergency
executive
emergency order and confirm that all
members of the committee and select
legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaries
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic media platform
and the public has access to conjecture
listen if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoo platform
or by the telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and choose the electronic calendar on
the general floor website
notice this meeting notices complies
with how schools and
rsa 91 anyone who has a problem
accessing
call 271-3600
leg dot state dot nh dot u
s in the event the public
is unable to access the meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want you to do some staff that are
let's start the meeting by taking the
roll call attendance
by the clerk thank you mr chair
representative yes
[Music]
david bindenberg president
esther sorry estafia
president myself
[Music]
griffith has a sub today it's
representative art ellison
a present uh thank you
tina harley here phyllis
cat's chorus here yes his phyllis
tony lebranch here
thank you stacey murray martin
i'm present
uh john lennon
dennis acton
dennis acton are you on
yes i am i just got the link just got in
okay
um okay do we have your we have to be
able to see you
uh in person are you in person there we
go
good morning uh signing in from fremont
thank you
uh linda massamia here
here skip rollins yeah
amanda elizabeth toe here
lawrence here
and matthew wilhelm i'm here good
morning
thank you
all right good morning um what i'm gonna
do is start off
with the pledge there and i have uh
representative uh
tina um
of the united states of america and to
the republic
for which it stands one nation under
thank you i'd like to do a moment of
silence for those
fellow warriors that are in harm's way
and those who made the ultimate
sacrifice
okay i want to open up this uh executive
session
uh we're going to be starting off with
hc 112
and uh representative
yeah i would uh thank you mr chairman
for recognizing me i'd like to motion uh
itl for hb 112.
uh reason being is because
[Music]
because uh immigration is handled by the
federal government under the commerce
clause all encryption
regulations are handled by the federal
government and a lot of this information
as was pointed out during the public
hearing
is already public information it can
already be compiled by
our non-profits right so school
districts
municipal governments and even non other
nonprofits publish
information on how um primary uh
primary earners within families how it
felt that they're deported so
all this information all this research
can already be done it doesn't need to
be paid for by new hampshire
taxpayers and um even if we did
such a study there's not much our state
can do
because it's out of our jurisdiction
this is something that would have to be
handled by our federal government so
seeing as
this is a federal issue and seeing as
this information can already be compiled
by any non-profit
anywhere in the country can compile our
information i find the uh i don't think
the bill
really services our constituents as a as
some might intend
is there anyone else that would like to
speak
yes uh mr chair thank you for the
opportunity to speak on representative
lawrence welcome it's from keene
can you hear me yeah great uh it's the
final plea to consider this important
bill
um to provide context i am a founding
member of two of those
non-profit organizations that uh the
keen immigration
refugee project and project home you're
in southwest
new hampshire i have very
a lot of difficulty finding that type of
information that was referenced here
for context i'm also a licensed new
hampshire licensed clinical psychologist
and i say this to let you know that i've
personally seen the economic and
psychological consequences
of ice detention and deportation of
primary breadwinners
in new hampshire families and i do think
we have a role to play here
i'd like to just briefly tell you and i
will
keep my remarks within three minutes i
promise
if i may we're in executive session the
three-minute rule can go away there
forget about that
we respect what you have to say so if
you've got to do four or five minutes
it's the floor shots great thank you mr
chairman
um i i'd like to just tell you very
briefly about the story of the ayala
family
of new hampshire this story uh happened
a couple years ago it was widely covered
in the new hampshire press and on wmur
it drew hundreds of people to
to the keene public library for on
thanksgiving day
in support of this family ayala was born
in central america he came to the us as
a child
and never became a us citizen he is the
father of four children
all born in the u.s all u.s citizens
he's a hard-working fellow he supported
his family
which never relied on government
services or handouts
one snowy day his car broke down i think
in milford and he sought help from
people in the neighborhood
one of whom called the police he was
identified as a non-us citizen
ultimately sent to an ice detention
facility in boston
without the primary breadwinner the
oldest son a high school student
increased his work hours as did the
mother one of the children who i
personally investigated had a
particularly rough time
missed his dad terribly his grades began
to suffer in school
without the dad the family had to rely
on services from the town the school the
state
i talked with the school counselor told
me that two of the children in the
family have been doing fine
until the father was taken away
requiring all sorts of
intervention in school services iep and
so on
taking mr ayala from his family not only
created a
psychological damage to the kids but it
was a bad economic
call for the state of new hampshire a
hard-working guy making a living
supporting his kids and wife one moment
a burden to the state the next after
separating him from his family of
american citizens
um so while i'd like you to open your
heart to this
family's plight i'd like to say
practically that this type of
separation is bad business for new
hampshire we have critical workforce
problems from finding someone who
you can't find someone right now to
repair your roof in the middle of the
winter and
in southwest new hampshire i know that
personally
if you have a leak in your in your roof
to high-tech foreign firms upstate
in the lakes region who are unable to
attract i.t
professionals we desperately need to
increase our workforce here in new
hampshire
deporting bread winners who are parents
to children who are american citizens is
not going to help
if you're concerned about the economic
consequences and if you can open your
heart to the plight of these families
then please consider voting in favor of
hb 112. thank you mr chairman
thank you are there any other hands up
i see a hand up in the father
manny representatives
thank you mr chair um espithia um no
worries i
get everybody fumbles the last name um
but um i just wanted to also raise my
objection to the itl
um and i just would like to to really
echo what our what my colleague
um representative walker would said you
know i think
um while well
i think it would show an imperative on
behalf of the state if we were to
analyze
what some of these what some of the
resources we have to use
for when when a breadwinner is deported
from
um and you know a lot of families here
are mixed status families they're not
just single not
not everyone in the family is
undocumented we have we have family
members who are in the process of
of receiving visas or who are already
citizens
so it's not it's not a black or white
issue it is a
very immigration in this country is a
very great issue
where it is not just oh like there are
there are there's this group and then
there's this group no it is
it is much more complex than that and i
think um
as somebody who's worked within the
system for the last couple of years
um i want to make sure that we do our
due diligence
in studying the effects that we have
that that
deportations have on on family members
in this
in this state um and so
i am i i i would support the overturning
of the itl
to not to pass and like i said this is
you know we have a humanitarian issue
right now
with what's going on with covet and the
number of
uh homeless people like the number of
homelessness that's that's
that's uh that's shooting up the number
of the the mental health crisis that's
going on in
in this not only in the state but in
this country um and so
um i would really i guess i really urge
you all to to
to look at um to look at changing this
from an ital to not to pass but um
with that i i appreciate you i
appreciate the time
okay so anyone else
uh thank you for recognizing me and i i
appreciate the uh both you know
the input from both of the colleagues
from across the isle but i just
i still we need to remember that the
question at the end of the day is about
whether or not to study the issue
while both tests you know both the
arguments that we just heard were very
strongly
you know against the idea of deporting
primary
earners we still have to remember that
it's still a federal issue
and two testimonies last week explain
that this data can already be compiled
by any private group that's against the
deportation of primary earners
and a study in the state compiling this
information doesn't change
the overall issue of our immigration
system that's already going to be
addressed
by the biden administration over the
coming months
it's just to collect this information
that's already available
so i think that's the biggest thing we
have to remember do we want the state to
be doing this and is this within the
state's jurisdiction
or is this a federal issue and should
this say you know if any government
entities can be handling it should it be
those
who actually regulate immigration i
believe in my personal opinion a number
of my colleagues
this is more of a federal issue and it
should be dressed at the federal level
and i hope that someone brings some kind
of language like this through chris
pappas
or to ann custer
that's all i have to say i rest bye
thank you i think i'm getting it up on
my phone now so i should be hoping
[Music]
um
okay i don't see any other hands up
i i'm going to speak on this here
representation
uh this bill came to us before and the
past year and of course under
the democrat watch it was out to pass
but what we realized
and we already know that the
constitution is the federalist
responsibility
federal government uh responsibility so
in my opinion this is a feel-good bill
uh where we're going to get together
we're going to pay mileage to state
representatives during the summer
i mean we can't even get democrats but
yet they're going to meet over the
summer again
i guess to assume or something i don't
but anyways um
[Music]
you know we recommended before that uh
the taxpayer dollars
once again for the constitution the
federal government is responsible for
all immigration enforcement matters
and custom enforcement so ice comes
under federal law
everyday immigration matters such as
application processes
are handled by the u.s citizenship and
immigration services
or the uscis customs and border
protection
is also a player guide not only the u.s
border but a broad swath of land within
it
plus other points of entry such as the
seaports
the study will have no effect on new
hampshire
it will just lead back to the federal
government and constitution
very simple that was my verb that i just
read that i
did done the last time uh this bill came
forward
so i can't you know support this and i
support the itl on this here because
like i said once again it's a feel good
tight
legislation great intentions i wish
there was something we could do
but really it is not it's a federal
issue
now with the new president uh the
uh they opened up the gates uh the
immigration just looking out borders
so apparently the federal government
here with them in today's world anything
goes
and they're not concerned with the
fossil fuels of the taxpayers
you know in different cities and towns
with the schools
so they want the federal government's on
it that's all i have
anyone else
okay um i don't see any other hands up
to you
okay with that i'm going to ask the
clerk to uh go to
a quote
the motion is on hb 112 is itl
and we'll go to vice chairman
moffett yes to ytl
yes to itl
dennis acton yes
yes skip rollins yes
myself yes david bindenberg yes
william foster yes
brody deshay yes
tina harley yes john levitt
yes linda massimo
no israel piedra
no estatia
burras uh if stathia boris no
boris pardon me i'm sorry
if i if i crucify your names please
straighten me out i certainly want to
say it correctly thank you
matthew wilhelm no
matty a speech yet no
what was griffith
willis griffith is not here it's
art ellison all right all right allison
thank you i'm sorry
okay thank you uh elizabeth told
no tony lebranch
no stacy marie lawton
no and lauren spoke with
no and oh
sorry and chairman bulbasaur yes
okay
correct 11 uh does the
minority have a uh committee report
they're going to submit here
today yes we do
okay i appreciate if you can submit that
um
who is author and uh doing the committee
report
um i think it is
espicia
all right uh the vice chair is doing a
report like who doesn't watch them
okay i'm going to close the house bill
and i will
i wish
yes hb 117 seeks to standardize how
things are done between the branches
align the state statute with dod rules
of force to ensure completeness
cohesiveness throughout the state of new
hampshire
on their department of defense and
national guard facilities
okay are there any other hands speaking
up
i see something bright does that
represent massimilia
i see flashing going on here
okay nobody else is looking to represent
the show
just just for some clarification this
makes it so that we're there we're
within
federal regulations for um the specific
uh
the use of force on any national guard
facilities so
federal governments pass legislation
we're just making it so then our
national guard facilities
are within such regulations
okay um thank you uh once again this
bill uh
came to us last year was past 14 to
nothing
and um it's a no-brainer
to um move forward with this and without
that if there's no other
questions i will do a vote
this is uh hb 117 octopass
and vice chairman mumpet
yes
yes skip rollins yes myself
yes david goodford yes william foster
yes rory de shea
yes tina harlan yes
john levitt yes linda massimilla
yes israel
yes
established yes
was that better yes thank you
thank you uh nathan wilhelm
yes yeah
yes and great job on that one too
all right allison yes amanda elizabeth
yes
yes stacey marie lawton
yes and lord spoke with
yes that's 21.
oh mr chairman right i'm sorry yes
thank you good lord i'm just going to
ask you something
so what that should be
okay uh without any objections uh we'll
put it on the consent
object okay
so you can send calendar
let's close
one second catch up
and then of course dave representative
did you have a
uh
[Music]
yes okay thank you
yourself okay
i'm going to open up the executive
session on hb 580
and i represented the series
yep i'd like to motion uh itl on
hp 580.
okay representative how many seconds of
motion
uh representative you want to speak
yeah so hp 580 has a good intent to try
to bring back
some constitutional conservatism to our
federal government and to ensure that
our state is following
such but there's many flaws with it and
how
we currently um regulate the federal and
state government regulates our national
guard as mobilization for duty for
example in 1986 the us congress passed
the montgomery amendment which
prohibited state governors from
withholding their
quote holding their consent to a
national guard unit's
active duty outside the country because
of an objection to the site purpose
or schedule of the duty the u.s supreme
court unanimously upheld this federal
statute in the 1990 case
pepperidge the department of defense in
2006 congress passed a 2007 national
defense authorization act
which gave the president the authority
to mobilize national guard units
within the u.s without the consent of
state governors
these laws in the site supreme court
precedent show us that the federal
government has the authority to deploy
national guard units
as long as such powers are mandated by
the constitution or
congress even if it's against the
governors or the state's desire
additionally there's the fear that this
legislation could cause the state of new
hampshire to lose
federal funding for our national guard
entitled 32 of the federal
code section 108 it states quote if
within a time fixed by the president a
state fails to comply
with a requirement of this title or
regulation prescribed under this title
the national guard
of that state is barred in whole or in
part
as the president may prescribe from
receiving money or any other aid benefit
or privilege
authorized by law end quote this means
if we mandate that new hampshire's
government
governor withhold our national guard
units
doing so against federal code then we
could lose federal funding
so this is a this could be a large risk
considering that
the president of the united states has
given a lot of uh authority
in title 32 of the federal code and
withholding our funding
and the fact that this bill because of
the warning it uses he uses the word
shall he use the word ciao for the
government for the governor
it's us imposing upon the governor
a requirement to withhold um
national guard units unless
if they feel if the legislature or the
governor feels as if
they've been deployed unconstitutionally
okay do i have any hands up from on the
screen
don't see any evidence to you okay um
i'm just gonna pass on uh just to
reinteract with
representatives uh we passed something
like this here with the concept
of the unconstitutional supreme court
like you said
while already answered on this nine to
nothing um with that if there's no
other entries or hands up then i
will move to a vote nasa clerk to
uh vote on the motion of itl
yes hb 580 it motioned to itl
um
representative bald sorrow well yes but
you have to go buddy
i'm sorry vice chairman yes to ito
okay and dennis acton yes
and phyllis cats of course yes
skip rollins yes myself yes
david binford yes william foster
yes rodney de chad yes
tina harmon yes john levitt yes
linda massimilla yes
israel theodora yes
estafa horus yes
matthew wilhelm yes
yes
yes elizabeth
no
stationary lawton
yes and lawrenceville police
yes and chairman
okay so yes uh on the representative
voted no
um daikiel will you be doing
uh if i do who do i send that to uh
you'll send it to me
okay thank you i need to know either yes
or no but possibly
i will write a minority report yes
i need the name what's your name again
uh this is representative tony lebranch
[Music]
l-a-b-r-a-n-c-h
so this will not be unconcerned no yeah
you asked her is okay or
no you see he's an inviting minority
caught on it so it's
just like the i'll object let's go to
the regular calendar
yes
it's so much easier when everyone's
sitting around here so i don't don't
even get
upset if i could i can't see i'm hoping
i get help
if i'm when you want to speak to put
your hand up
so i'm trying not to miss anybody
because
my phone is not really showing it's only
just showing a picture of the
you know the room here so bear with me
are we all set actually yeah
okay
executive session on hcr1
and representative representative
yes i'd like to make a motion to itl
hcr1 i have a motion on the floor the
itl
do i have a second i i will second that
okay
yes thank you uh chairman stalisario
i believe that any objective
weighing of these comes down heavily on
the side
of risks and hazards especially heavily
does it come down so when the amendments
are claimed to be necessary
to get the constitution to do what
it is written to do i.e constrain the
federal government
this benefit will obviously not be added
to a constitution
whose problem is the federal government
is ignoring it
yet the proponents want us to put our
very constitution
at risk in order to fix a fault
that is not the constitution any such
proposal
needs to have weighed the risk and
hazards
of such a convention over against
its potential for benefits particularly
for such benefits as the convention
proponents
promise
is there anyone else that's looking to
speak to this bill
you see anyone up there with their hands
oh yeah representative
representative of a bunch uh i was going
to bring forward an amendment uh
i'm not new to procedure is it too late
to bring forward that amount
oh it's not too late but we're gonna
once we take a vote
uh we've already got a motion on the
floor to itl
uh once they vote if the itl fails
then the next motion would be an
artifact and then the amendment would be
able to come forward
okay thank you mr chair
i wish i got an email on that video and
let me know that
you got one i don't know i can't speak
forever
let's go to the motion here before we
discuss
8 23 in the morning
as you see okay
um anyone else looking to speak uh on
the motion ito representative
yeah i'll say something real brief uh
the largest issue with
the um with the resolution is the fact
that there are
no unified within our constitution there
is no established rules
for how such a convention would work so
there's no established rules for
how you would uh pass an amendment you
know on the floor there there's no
established rules for
how many delegates each state would send
there's no established rules for
how you would even establish the rules
for such a convention so it's such a
gray area
and it's up to so much ambiguity and
even within
these resolutions not every single
resolution is entirely the same from
every state that's been trying
to push for uh the article 5 convention
on a number of levels for a number of
reasons we're going to uh
touch upon hcr4 after i think another
thing to the
termination correct me if i'm wrong but
this is a concurrent resolution
which i believe it means it has to also
go to the senate
there we go and the senate
most likely will not take up such a
resolution they have rules against
so with that i'll yield okay uh i'm
going to add
to this here especially for the freshmen
so you know
the state of new hampshire does have a
resolution on file for a balanced budget
okay when i was a chair a few years back
um
we passed that okay and then of course i
educated myself on constitution
dimension
you know and read the federalist uh
papers and stuff on it and
i actually changed my whole view
okay on concert on constitutional
conventions
so for rebel events i'm not sure if
you're aware we are
on fire along with about 25 80 28 states
uh for a balanced budget uh anyone else
have anything
okay with that um this is seeing that
there's no
more questions on this discussion
concurrent resolution one ipo
right hcr one motion itl
and vice chairman
yes skip rollins yes
myself yes uh david
no
foster williams uh sorry
william foster yes
rudy
yes israel
yes all right ellis
uh it's ellison yes oh excuse me
that's all right sorry uh art ellison
yes yes sorry uh
amanda elizabeth yes
tony lebranch no
stacy marie lawton yes reports
yes
okay
oh and uh and sorry and she's you're
involved
get my good lord um
the two um will you be
pregnant minority report on its way
chairman about this area that's the
majority okay
thank you thank you
and i just sent the minority report
with all this virtual stuff
who doesn't represent a call okay uh
first of all hold on
i won't close you guys let me see what
he's got um representative pope
told i'll i just oh honorable chairman i
just wanted to let you know that i sent
them
the minority report to you for um 112 as
well
my good friend massimo must be cracking
the whip on you guys
keep up the good work we appreciate the
team effort
never crack a whip
unless you're dealing with horses linda
just elbows
when i'm near you absolutely
thank you representative
give us a few seconds to get our notes
together
[Music]
be on the regular calendar
representative mas miller on hcl1
uh is anyone going to be taking this on
on the floor
uh not that i know of chairman
okay i don't think um uh
republicans are gonna speak on it you
know unless the minority's gonna speak
right now i can tell you we're not gonna
fight you know
speak on the floor you know
you might wanna ask a representative le
branch
because i can't speak for him
uh i probably will not speak on the
house floor to this
okay thank you
okay
open up the executive session on
hcr4
representatives
we have a motion it'll do we have any
second i said
that
yes i will second the motion to itl hdr4
we'll go represent the branch the second
uh because he did have his hand up uh
he was
so as previously mentioned with hcr1
there's a
large amount of ambiguity regarding
adopting rules for an article 5
convention but
as already i've already previously
mentioned that but i'll touch upon a
different aspect for hcr4
in regards to its content which it does
not guarantee the objective
of its uh of the resolution itself and
could actually have contrary results
so if you're a conservative who's
concerned about the the right to life
this could do
the exact ops during article 5
prevention any conceivable amendments
can come to fruition
and he suggests a constitutional
amendment made by the convention
can be later ratified by individual
states and if enough individual states
ratify the amendments
they become adopted in our credit
constitution this high
this hypothetical convention could
suggest amendments that prevent
very reasonable limits on abortion
procedures or for my more um
for my pro-choice members on this
committee to do the exact opposite too
it could have extremely stringent
uh regulations upon abortion which might
be favorable to some but
unfavorable to others and we enter into
this article 5
convention with a lot of ambiguity for
what comes out of it so i think the best
way for um
for us to handle this kind of policy
issue is for us to have debates
in our house chamber within committees
to have debates in our state senate
to sign laws uh to sign
bills into law and to then debate in our
code
over the merits of such laws not to have
a debate
in an article five convention where
there's no rules for this ambiguity for
what will happen
or there's ambiguity to final results
okay uh anyone else looking to speak
any hands up out there
you'll see
what that let me just look at something
yeah
okay since there's no one else oh did
you ever end up
no okay uh with that i'll ask the roll
call
to take the vote on the ipo
on hcr4 okay yes
uh bill hcr4 motion is itl
we'll call vice chairman profit yes to
itl
uh dennis acton yes
phyllis scott yes skip rollins
yes yes
david yes william foster
yes brody uh
is yes boris yes matthew wilhelm
yes daddy escepia yes
are ellison yes
uh amanda elizabeth yes
yes stacey murray
yes and lawrence welcome yes
[Music]
zero
objection of this going on a consent
put on the objection it will be on the
consent calendar
yeah i just didn't think we're gonna
pass this unanimously so i gotta make a
quick little edit
okay thank you
i'm going to close the executive session
on hcr4
i'm going to give the clerk a few
seconds to catch up
yes
okay
[Music]
oh
that's
hey
okay the executive session
on hr9
and representative uh
you have a motion yes i make a
motion of ought to pass
on hr9 i'll second it
who seconded it representative massa
milla
okay
yes hr 9 is a resolution which supports
and recognizes both the state and
federal authority and the relationship
between the two
with the powers not the with the powers
that are not delegated to the united
states by the constitution
nor prohibited by it to the states and
are reserved by the states respectively
which ultimately is to the people
anyone else
who is
i i just want to make one comment mr
chairman thank you for the opportunity
to speak
um i just want to remind all of us about
uh federalism that there were that there
are amendments that are not mentioned
in any of these documents about
amendments that were adopted
after the civil war it's black history
month so it's important to mention
amendments 13 14 and 15 which freed the
slaves gave blacks the right to vote
prevented poll taxes and preserve the
union
so we have to work with both state and
federal
uh guidelines and this is why
i'm opposing this amendment thank you
baldassaram um
i withdraw my second because i thought
we were doing hr8
we already did hre yes we did hr8
which already was done last week okay
um on our list that we got for executive
session
on twi uh two for 212 hr8 was there so
that's why
i seconded it it was supposed to be uh
hr9 okay so i i will not second hr 9.
that's fine we have uh representatives
[Music]
anyways okay well seeing that there's
uh no hands
no one else looking to speak you're
online now that's the card to take day
okay this is a roll call vote on uh
hr9 motion is otp
and vice chairman moffitt
yes to otp
dennis acton yes
those cats of course yes skip rollins
yes myself yes david
yes william foster
yes brody duchess yes
tina garland yes john levitz yes
no israel paper
no these are not
of course no
no no
uh no
lauren spelkowitz no
and uh chairman vulcan yes
okay uh who will the doing the
minority report that would be
representative welkowitz
okay okay
and i want to thank everyone here for
coming forward
in two days there so now you can you
know do more stuff with other committees
and
then you're involved in uh business
the next time we'll get together is
during the crossover
a great meeting
massimo would have beat me up if i did
okay yeah is nothing else that we have
we're all set there uh
we are all set thank you very much i
only asked uh
representative welkowitz could you give
me a call please
we'll do okay thank you representative
massimilia
i'm not sure whether they're going to
take this on the floor
uh let me know i'll do
okay thank you hr's
not you know how we are his not worth a
fight yet because they go to washington
and somebody's draw
so if we have to you know go back and
forth
hey thank you mr chairman thank you you
all have a great time